in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
and with me in the studio now is dr
manfred tetz he's the director of an eye
clinic here in berlin and you conducted
more than 60 000 eye operations
yourselves that's right that's correct
yeah wow what a great number
talking about glaucoma what is the cause
of this disease
well our eyeball needs to inflate itself
it doesn't do that with air it does it
with water the own aqueous what we call
it
and to keep its form and to work nicely
now this water is consistently built and
it needs to flow out of the eye and this
goes through a mesh work like a sponge
and into a canal which is called the
schlemm's canal and if there is an imp
impedance in this system and the water
can go out easily the pressure goes up
and this causes damage to the optic
nerve so it's something about the
draining of the waters of getting it out
of the eye it's not about production
that's correct
okay and who's at a particular risk for
developing glaucoma well the classic
primary open angle glaucoma is the
disease of the elderly so the risk
increases as we're getting older because
this system suffers from aging in in
other words so every decade the risk
doubles to develop glaucoma above the
age of 40. and what about genetics can
you inherit glaucoma yes there is a
genetic risk and that risk is in the
means that if you have family members
with an open angle glaucoma the risk
increases three to nine fold
okay so if my grandma suffered from
glaucoma i'm very likely to uh suffer
from you're more likely at a three to
nine times more
what about on a worldwide view are there
some nations who suffer more from
glaucoma than others yes um if you have
a darker skin so the darker the color of
your skin the higher the risk for
glaucoma it actually increases
by about five to six times
how long does it take for glaucoma to
develop and and how rapidly might it
lead to blindness well it's a chronic
damage of the optic nerves of course if
the pressure is very high you know
normal pressure 10 to 20 but if it's
very high 50 or 60 which we sometimes
see in africa then the damage can occur
quite fast within one or two years but
normally it takes several years to even
decades to chronically damage nerve
fiber by nerve fiber and is there a way
for the patient to tell that he's got a
elevated eye pressure if the patient
notices visual field defects in his
daily life already 70 of his optic nerve
are damaged so yes there is a way to
notice it but you should actually know
this before the damage has come to that
point because it's very late in the
cause of the disease late in the cause
of the disease yes so so um if you go to
an eye doctor and he says yes you've got
glaucoma what's the usual treatment
well there's usually a stage treatment
and the old-fashioned treatment strategy
is first to use eye drops to lower the
intraocular pressure secondly you might
try several laser means for the mesh
work for the outflow system and finally
there is glaucoma surgery however with
more modern glaucoma surgeries which
address the outflow system itself the
canal that is actually impeded
the
the means are used earlier so there is
also a tendency towards earlier surgical
treatment of glaucoma with modern
technology and what about the laser
treatment is it superior to to using a
knife
laser treatment in general is being used
in the eye a lot of times but we are
talking now about a certain laser called
alt
which is not superior to knife because
the
the the
working action is not lasting as long as
it should do okay
when light falls into our eye it has to
pass through the lens a tiny structure
in the front of the eyeball and if this
lens is clear light passes through it
perfectly but sometimes the lens gets
cloudy impeding our vision this
condition is called a cataract and if i
suffer from a cataract is an operation
surgery the only way to go yes currently
it's the only way to go we need to
replace the cloudy lens by a clear one
but if you replace the lens you healed
and you're not getting blind
that's correct
and and why is it that cataract is the
major cause for blindness all over the
world if it's so easily treated well
according to the who it is really a
major cause for blindness and the reason
for that that in a lot of countries not
like germany or the us
people do not have access to the medical
systems in a way that we have access to
it so it's actually a lack of access of
a lot of patients for having the
cataract surgery performed
dr tetz can we leave this artificial
lens in there forever or does it have to
come out some point nowadays modern
lenses that are put in the eye replacing
the cataract lens will remain there till
the patient dies so yes we can leave it
in there and is there any risk of the
body rejecting the artificial lens the
artificial lens does not get in any
contact with vascularized tissues it's
actually in the old container of the
original lens and the so-called capsular
back away from everything that is
important so
yes
it is no major risk for this implant to
be rejected and the patient cannot feel
the lens itself
there is no nerve tissue in the vicinity
nothing okay great and this artificial
lens doesn't cloud up it doesn't get
blurred but the natural lens in the
first place was blurred so what causes
the lens to blur well our lens is made
from very special proteins these
proteins are
beauty of the nature they're crystal
clear we can look through it but like
everything in the body everything does
age and these
proteins the so-called crystalline they
do age and as they age they change um
their composition and then the lens
itself becomes cloudy and at the end it
obstructs our vision
is it
are you able to suffer at the same time
from glaucoma and cataract yes it's
actually not very uncommon especially
with some syndromes like
pseudoexfoliation in the elderly it's an
elderly disease so they have a cataract
they have a glaucoma and especially in
these patients modern types of surgeries
like schlemm's canal surgery as it was
shown in the illustration before can be
nicely combined with the cataract
operation in fact the effect of the
pressure lowering is better if you
combine cataract and schlemm's canal
surgery than if you do one and the other
separate okay and is there any way
preventing those diseases like glaucoma
and cataract in the first place well
prevention is not really the right term
because you notice glaucoma very late so
for glaucoma you have to see an eye
doctor above the age of 40
regularly to check whether there's any
disease beginning if you notice it
yourself it's too late in the cataract
you will notice some visual
deterioration once you notice that this
is the time to see your eye doctor but
in the glaucoma there's no early onset
signs for the patients no unfortunately
not if they've the patients notice their
visual field defects is already late
disease more than 70 percent of the
optic nerve are gone so how often again
does do patients need to get their eye
testosterone we recommend about 40 that
they have their eyes checked every two
to three years and above 65 at least
annually okay anything to do with
nutrition can you save your eyes using
the right nutrients
well for cataract we do not know
anything that has shown in studies that
it will really prevent the
lens from going cloudy it's like can we
prevent aging in general it's very
difficult
thanks so much for being with us in the
studio you're welcome
you